The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I hope you all had a good break.
I came back from San
Francisco on Sunday.
So last time, we talked about
Boltzmann transport equation,
and we made a drastic
approximation.
That's a relaxation
time approximation.
So using this relaxation
time approximation,
the original Boltzmann
transport equation,
on the right-hand side
was a scattering term.
If you recall, we said that
it's the [INAUDIBLE] right?
Because we say, when we
have two particles colliding
with each other, we have to
sum up all the possibilities
for the collision.
But using the relaxation
time approximation,
we say all those
collisions eventually
drive the system back
to an equilibrium F0.
So that F0 is the equivalent
distribution function.
And we also
commented-- actually,
this is not really strict.
This is, of course,
a approximation.
There are many ways
it's not correct.
And later on, you'll see that,
in fact, this approximation
will not give you the right
[INAUDIBLE] when you calculate
the fluid properties.
And for relaxation time, we
discuss different scattering
mechanisms, for example, phonon
scattering, electron phonon
scattering, and
scattering by impurities.
And we say, if I have multiple
scattering mechanisms,
I use the methods and rule
where the total relaxation
time is the inverse of all the
scattering processes involved
in the transport.
And I want to also make
the additional comment
that, even though, you
can solve the Boltzmann
equation in this format on the
relaxation time approximation.
And often, the
largest uncertainty
come from this relaxation time.
We do not have a good way to
calculate relaxation time.
We say you go to quantum
mechanical Fermi,
say Golden rule to
calculate, so that way you
have to go to quantum mechanics.
And in fact, that's a active
research topic, for example,
immediately jumping into
thermal conductivity
prediction of phonon thermal
conductivity prediction.
And a recent large step
that's made in this field
is the ability to actually
use the density function
theory to calculate
this relaxation time.
And using this relaxation
time, as a fade
into the Boltzmann
equation, so you can now
say computer the property
like thermal conductivity
of the materials.
So this is where
we were last time,
and today, we're going to
solve this Boltzmann question
in the classical limit.
Where if you recall,
in the second lecture,
we went through a very
approximate derivation
of the [INAUDIBLE] law of heat
conduction and also Ohm's law,
and you had a homework
on Fick's law.
So all those laws we
did very [INAUDIBLE]
but now we can use this
equation, re-derive it.
So we went through
a really long cycle
to come back to
our second lecture.
And I'm going to show you,
today, hopefully, or cover
a Fourier law.
We'll cover Ludenshur's stress
law, and we'll cover Ohm's law.
OK.
So let's first say, look at the
general solution, proximate.
So Boltzmann transfer equations
ia already an approximation,
but when I lecture
solve it, I was
under diffusion approximation.
So I will do a small
perturbation method
and solve the Boltzmann
equation, together,
diffusion laws, so let's
say diffusion approximation.
Again, here, I'm
making approximation.
Again, you can
say what you learn
had knowledge of
approximation made.
OK?
And let's say, so what I
mean, diffusion approximation
is when I try to
solve the Boltzmann
equation under the relaxation
time approximation,
you can say they use
a perturbation method.
The f deviates from
f0 only slightly.
So the difference
gives me g, and this g
is orders of magnitude
smaller than f0.
Right?
You can do more rigorous math
versus a asymptotic method,
but the basic assumption
I'm making is g
is much smaller than
f and f0 itself.
And let's also say, because of
this F equals the f0 plus g,
so I'm going to substitute
into the Boltzmann equation,
and I have df0 dt plus dg, dt
plus v. I'll just make one more
comment, this v now in
the Boltzmann equation
should be considered.
This is the group
velocity of the particle.
That's the particle carrying
energy at this velocity.
So this is v dot f0 and v dot g.
And this is an r.
Right?
Remember, f itself is
a function of time,
is a function of a space, xyz,
is also functional momentum
px/pl py/pz.
It's a quantity one
particle distribution
function in the phase space.
And on the second
term, I have f.
Now, this is the gradient in
the momentum's components,
and f dot gradient
pg equals g mass tau.
Right?
OK?
So I'm seeking the
first-order solution.
g is much smaller than f and f0.
So the approximation,
which you can do more,
like I said, better
math, but basically,
on the left-hand side, all this
higher-order grid in term on g
drops out, under
my approximation.
OK?
And later on, we'll
come back to re-discuss
when this is not valid.
Right?
And that's, in fact, the
[? kind ?] of lecture,
last chapter, when we discussed
classical size effects.
So those drop out,
and let me further,
for the conceptual equation,
like a Fourier law,
let me drop also the df0 dt.
In fact, [INAUDIBLE] OK?
Because the f0 is a
symmetric function.
So let me just say
the steady state.
This is not a [? censure, ?]
so I can drop the time term.
And then with this,
I have g minus tau
and the v dot r f0
plus f dot p f0.
Right?
And so I am more
used to f itself.
So I can go back
to add back the f0.
So f equals f0 plus g, so I
have r f0 plus f dot p f0.
OK.
So this is my solution.
For the distribution
function f, when I have the,
later on you'll
see, this will be
reflected in terms of
temperature gradient, velocity
gradient, or electrical field.
These are all included in the
gradient [? form ?] terms.
OK?
So this is my approximation.
I have the solution.
I'm going to use
this to get my flux.
When I want to
calculate heat transfer,
I'm interested in heat flux.
When I want to calculate charge
and really see the current,
I'm interested in
the current flux.
And/or in terms of the
stress, shear stress,
I'm interested in
the momentum flux.
So force, energy,
and charge, right?
So let's do first
the fourier law.
I'm going to use a
phonon as my prototype
in deriving the Fourier
law, and in this case,
let's look at the
phonon heat conduction.
Right?
And I have a medium with
a temperature gradient.
Let's say, this is z direction,
and this t is a function of z.
one dimensional, make it easy.
You can do arbitrary
3D easily extension.
So in this case, my local
f, because each z point,
there's a temperature.
And that the f0, the
corresponding equilibrium
distribution is the Boltzmann
Einstein distribution.
Right?
So let's write down
the [? bose-einstein ?]
distribution as exponential
h bar omega kbt minus 1.
Right?
So you can see, f we said
is a function one particle
distribution function
in phase space.
There's an equilibrium.
In the case of equilibrium,
it's a function
of omega, the energy, not
just another momentum.
Right?
It depends on energy and
depends on temperature.
Temperature it is
a function of z.
So when I do the spatial
gradient, r, the df0,
the spatial grid that
is df0 dz and vz.
This term I do not have
force, external force acting
[INAUDIBLE] right?
So this term drops out.
So now, I'm going
to do my f equals
f0 minus tau with z df0 dz is
a dt If I use a the [INAUDIBLE]
rule, it's dt dz.
Right?
OK.
Now, I have f as a function.
Now, you can say f0
itself is isotropic,
because it doesn't depend on
direction [INAUDIBLE] omega.
But the f is not isotropic,
because this velocity z
has direction.
Right?
So if I have a phonon,
actually, in solid,
it goes all directions.
It's a random motion.
Of course, now, it's a
biased random motion,
because there is a
temperature gradient.
Right?
So phonon with
the group velocity
in this direction,
then the z component
is v times cosine zeta.
Right?
Now, f itself has direction,
and but say f0 is isotropic.
Now, I'm going to
calculate heat flux.
So heat flux, this
is the distribution
of one specific quantum state.
OK?
One partygoer distribution
function at a specific quantum
state with certain momentum
px/py/px [INAUDIBLE] OK?
So if you recall, when
I do specific heat,
I sum up all quantum states.
So I'm going to do the same.
I'm going to do this
summation of kx, ky, kz.
I'm doing momentum space now.
Right?
The q is a function
in real space.
So I sum up of all
possible quantum states,
that feel the momentum space.
kx, ky, different momentum.
And then each mode, I have a x
bar omega, that's the energy.
right?
That's a 1 phonon
energy, and then I
have this many phonon
in that quantum state.
And if I have polarization,
I add a polarization.
Because if you think about
what we learned before
on phonon dispersion, this
is specific k direction.
I have say transfers phonon
longitudinal [INAUDIBLE]
up to phonons.
Right?
So I have to sum up
over all those phonon
modes, and each mode I have my
solution on how many phonons
at that specific mode, given
this local temperature t.
And this will now
giving me flux.
If I divide by volume,
you will get the flux.
Oh, sorry, I have--
this is the energy.
Right?
If you do specifically f0,
this is your energy density.
But I have to do the
fluxes of velocity.
It's moving at vz.
So it's vz, that's the
component in the z direction.
That's the [INAUDIBLE]
flux in the z direction.
OK?
So once you know how to
write this term from here,
next is, say you
have your solution f,
is converting this
summation into integration.
That's what we did before
for dense substates.
Right?
However, when we did
the density of states,
we didn't care about directions.
And this when we do
flux for transport,
I have to be careful
on direction.
OK?
I'll still use dense
substates but with a twist.
So let's go to write
down those other terms.
I'm going to convert so q,
I look at that summation,
is a discrete
number, you recall.
Right?
If I want to convert it
into integration, I say dkx.
That's a [? legacy ?]
in the kx direction.
I say each mode the spacing
is a 2 pi divided by L. Right?
So the number of points is 2 pi
over lx, If I have lengths dkx.
So by using this--
I convert this sum over kx how
many points into integration.
So I have kx integration.
I have dky and 2 pi over
ly dkz 2 pi over lz.
In the past, I just
used the same l.
It doesn't matter, because at
the end, the volume cancel.
lx/ly/lz cancel.
Right?
So I have my three integrals.
This is now kx, ky, kz,
and I have to my sum
different polarization,
different branches p,
and volume.
And the rest is
still [INAUDIBLE] vz
so I have h bar omega vz.
f f0 minus tau vz df0 dt dt dz.
I'm just copying what I have
in this expression here.
Right?
So the key is converting this
submission into integration,
and now, I have dkx, dky, dkz.
I have 8 pi, 2 pi
cubic, and the v cancel.
I'm going to skip one
step, because there are too
many of this kind of writing.
Now, you have the choice
how to do this integration.
Right?
In the past, when
we do specific heat,
it's always easier
to convert this
into integration over energy.
Right?
Because the f0, here,
is a function of omega.
So you say, OK, either
I integrate over omega,
or I integrate or dkx, dky, dkz.
But see before, it was a
pretty symmetric when I do
energy, and here, I
have the problem of v
is a function of
the rationality.
This is a directional.
Directional in the phase space,
because this is random group
velocity over the particles.
Right?
So how I do this
integration, dkx, dky, dkz?
For this specific problem,
I'm going to convert this
into a spherical coordinate.
OK?
So dky dkz, this one, is if
I do a spherical coordinate,
I cannot do just a
4 pi k square dk,
because I have the
rational dependence.
So I have to do integrate.
So this is my theta
and in the kx ky plane,
I have an angle phi,
spherical coordinate.
So if I write dkx, dky, dkz,
in spherical coordinate,
I get sine theta
d theta k squared,
like r square, sine
theta [INAUDIBLE] dk dr.
That's my dkx, dky, dkz.
When I do energy before, I
just simply already integrated
sin theta, d theta and d phi.
That's give me a 4 pi.
I can't do that because
here I have a directionality
in my integram.
OK?
So now I do--
you can see because I'm doing
this spherical corner like k,
I can use--
because at the end, I still have
to choose between k integration
or omega integration.
Because the f itself is omega.
Right?
I have the relation between
different value of k and omega.
That's my dispersion.
That's what we went
through before.
So the way to do
it is say, dk, you
can write dk into dk,
d omega and d omega.
And dk, d omega, if
you use a dispersion,
k squared, dk, d omega.
And you can convert everything
back into thin substrates.
Except that [INAUDIBLE] before
is a 4 pi k squared, dk.
There is a 4 pi.
But here, because I
have to carry the angle,
so I don't have the 4 pi.
So I have to be--
there is an extra 4
pi in this conversion.
So now I'm going
to do converter.
Rather than kx, ky,
kz integration limit,
I'm going to do sine, so
in theta phi and k limit--
omega limit.
Because here, I'm doing
the omega integration.
So I have 0 to omega max.
That's whatever the photon
dispersion of the material is.
That's the maximum
frequency you integrate to.
And you will see
the phi integration.
Phi here, the kx, ky
plan, that's 0 to 2 pi.
OK?
So I have 0 to 2 pi.
That's a d phi.
And theta, what's the
integration limit of theta?
0 to the other side is pi.
So the photon go both
directions, all directions.
So the [INAUDIBLE] difference
is forward, backward.
The picture we had before
in the second lecture
is that I have any
imagined surface,
photon go across that surface.
Is forward, the
difference the backwards
give me the left flux.
And here, I'm doing that
more mathematically.
It's going in all directions.
So here I have 0 to pi.
This is my d phi.
This is my d theta.
And this will be my d omega.
And the rest is polarization,
2 pi, 2 pi, 2 pi.
And all this together gives me
density of states over 4 pi.
That 4 pi is because,
like I mentioned before,
is a 4 pi k squared dk.
I don't have theta
phi integration.
OK?
So this-- and the rest
is f minus tau vz, now.
vz, if I think about,
this is group velocity.
It project into,
in the z direction
is a v, times cosine theta.
So I have tau, v,
cosine theta, v squared,
cosine theta squared, df
0, dt, dt, dz integration.
And I have sine theta
that's still there
in my spherical coordinate.
OK?
So my theta sine theta and
I have cosine theta squared.
f0 itself is a isotropic.
If you look at my
f0, it's isotropic.
Now you can tell, what's the
integration of first term?
Of 0 term?
Sine theta integrated
between 0 pi is what?
0.
f0 term drops out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
times with cosine.
GANG CHEN: f0--
AUDIENCE: Then it should--
GANG CHEN: Oh, I'm sorry.
OK, because of vz.
vz, here.
Yeah, yeah, f0.
So here, I missed this.
Because when I'm multiplying,
is v cosine theta.
OK, you're right.
Otherwise, it's a cosine
theta that's not 0.
So, right?
This one, vz multiply in.
Here, I have it squared.
The first term is
the v cosine theta.
Now integrate cosine
theta, sine theta.
You integrate between
0 and pi d theta.
That's one half cosine theta
squared, is 0, because 0 2 pi.
So the first term drops out.
And the second term
is a cosine theta
squared, sine theta integrate.
So that will give you one
third cosine theta cubed.
See, cosine theta squared,
sine theta, d theta, the one
[INAUDIBLE] cosine theta cubic.
And they integrate-- there is
a negative sign in the front
because sine theta go back to
negative cosine theta, right?
So there is a negative sign.
But a 0 2 pi, that
gives me another 2.
So there's another
negative sign.
So this one I
actually gave me 3/2--
2/3, 2/3.
I'm sorry.
2/3-- my fraction, so
Chinese way is the reverse.
OK?
So what I have is 2/3 and
tau v squared, df 0, dt.
This term drop out, this 2/3.
I don't have phi dependence.
That's because of my
density of states and fact
that I have made
approximation, OK?
If you consider real
crystal in each direction,
you have to do thin
substrates in each direction,
is also different.
But under my approximation
here, 0 2 pi, there's
no other phi dependence.
So the integration
just give me 2 pi.
So I have another 2 pi.
And then I have my density
of states, u omega, 4 pi.
And I'm going to pull dt dz--
that's a constant I
pull out of integration.
So I have negative dt, dz,
0 omega max and d omega.
So this is a rederivation
of Fourier's law.
What you have here is the
thermal conductivity, k.
And the heat flux is
proportional to the temperature
gradient that comes
from this term.
And the proportionality
constant thermal conductivity,
we look at it.
What do we have here?
2 pi, 2-- that's a 4
pi, cancel this 4 pi.
So it's 1/3.
So thermal conductivity,
k, is one third integration
0 2 omega max.
OK, I have df, dt times
density of states--
oh, I should have h omega 10.
That term should still be there.
I come back here.
I missed, here we
have h bar omega.
That's this term here.
OK.
So what I have h bar omega,
times density of states times
df 0 dt is a specific heat
at that specific frequency.
OK?
So this is a tau v squared
specific heat as d omega.
Each of these term
could depend on omega.
And if we go back to notes
before [INAUDIBLE] we said,
thermal conductivity is specific
heat, velocity mean free path.
That's what we did in
the second lecture.
Now we have a more
rigorous expression.
And each term now depends
on specific heat--
it depends on frequency.
OK.
Because it's so hard to measure
the mean free path, right?
And I'm not sure I give this
homework problem before.
One way is OK, I
take the measure
of thermal connectivity.
I take a measure specific heat.
I take a speed of sound.
I go to calculate
the mean free path.
But there is a big difference
between this and this,
in terms of the details.
The expression
looks very similar.
If you do this for
silicon, you'll
get a 40 nanometer of the
mean free path of silicon.
But this is a very,
very wrong, OK?
And the people use
that all the time.
That's because if you look at
this, photon dispersion, right?
And group velocity
for contribute
they say very small in
the [INAUDIBLE] photon.
You see, [INAUDIBLE] photon
group velocity is very small.
When I take the speed
of sound, that's here--
very large value.
But the real speed of sound as
a group velocity for [INAUDIBLE]
number is small.
So they do not contribute
much to the heat conduction,
normally.
But see, if I use the
measure specific heat,
due to a high temperature, they
contribute to specific heat.
So I'm overestimating
the specific heat
for this, that carries
heat in the material.
Secondly, my group
velocity, right?
If you see, the speed of
sound is here, the tangent,
but the group velocity
is changing to 0
as it moves along
the dispersion.
So again, I'm overcounting
the velocity here.
So that estimation gives
you a very round result.
And this, like I
said, 40 nanometer.
And it turns out that
some of those photon
has a mean free path as
long micron or even longer.
According to some
of the calculations
we did, in silicon,
about half of the heat
is carried by photon with a mean
free path longer than micron.
So that's the
difference there, right?
When you start to count the size
effect, if you use from here,
it's 40 nanometer.
That's when you start
to pay attention.
But if you go from
here, you'll say, OK.
My understanding is I need to be
worried about that when you it
from micron range.
Different conclusions.
Now if you look
at a typical curve
of the thermal conductivity,
you do this integration, right?
And you go to check
for most crystals,
the thermal conductivity,
k, versus temperature looks
like this bell shape.
OK?
That peak in typical
material happens around 20
or a few tens of Kelvins.
Of course, it change with
the different materials.
At a high temperature, this
range is T to the n-th power.
And the theory is roughly T to
the first-- but at this end,
could be 1 to 1.5 range.
Why is this?
Why, at high temperature,
the thermal conductivity
drop with temperature?
If you check the specific
heat, if you recall,
for solid, specific heat
has a function temperature.
This is a [INAUDIBLE] regime.
Each mol contribute
1/2 kbT to energy,
so specifically,
there's a constant,
because of T derivative.
And this regime is T
cubic at low temperature.
And this here is about T
cubic, and this here is about 1
over T.
So what's happening there?
The reason is, you
see here, specifically
heat is a constant.
That means the energy
is T, proportional to T.
And so when you get
to higher temperature,
photon has higher energy.
They move more violently
and they scatter more.
So in this regime,
the relaxation time
is the inverse
proportionate to energy,
so that's the inverse
proportional to temperature.
Once they go through this
regime, as you cool down,
the photon scatter and weakens.
So photon scattering
do not happen
as you go to lower temperature.
The mean free path becomes long.
And typically, in this
regime, the mean free path
can get to centimeters.
So that reached the sample
size, and the mean free path
becomes comparable
to the sample size.
So it's a constant.
And then the mean free path
is tau times v, is a constant.
Specific heat is appropriate
to cubic, thermal conductivity
is appropriate to cubic.
And in this regime, where
our fallen photon is weak,
what's really important
is impurities.
I mentioned they say
impurity scatter,
like really scatters--
fourth power.
And so for example, diamond,
which is the best conductor,
it turns out that most
material, it has a isotopes--
diamond, silicon.
If you make them--
even remove the isotope, just
to make the same atomic mass,
isotopically enrich
it, you actually
boost the thermal
conductivity by a few times
if you can do that.
So you want at the
room temperature there.
I don't know whether that's
settled, but most likely,
even at room temperature
in most material
like silicon and diamond, the
isotope, if you purify it,
the isotope will
actually-- you can
increase thermal conductivity.
So I heard this
a few years back,
probably 15 years back,
they were reported
that isotope-enriched
silicon has a 60% higher
thermal conductivity.
And somebody told me there was
a big factory built just to make
the isothermal rearrange the
silicon because the heat cannot
go out from the chips.
I'm not sure whether they were
successful at the end or not.
So that's thermal conductivity.
This is the example
of Fourier's law.
Let's look at the flow problem.
OK.
Now I'm going to look at
the Newton Shear Stress.
I have a flow.
And the simplest flow
is a [INAUDIBLE] flow.
When I have one plate
fixed, the other plate
drag parallel plates.
And the velocity-- say if this
is my x, so my dl was this.
This is my y.
And I have-- in this
case, when I have flow,
a significant difference
is now the average velocity
of the molecule is not zero.
So it's not completely random.
And in the [INAUDIBLE] flow, I
have linear velocity profile.
So any place I have velocity,
u, and the v, of course,
is 0 for the [INAUDIBLE] flow.
And v u is the function y.
So in this case, the f0,
what's the proper f0?
And you can go to saw really
the full words of my equation.
But a good approximation this
is a part of the [INAUDIBLE]
equation is the f0 now is--
rather than f0 is an fd.
it's a displaced Boltzmann.
And the displaced Boltzmann
is say-- remember,
the Boltzmann factor
is mv squared,
divided by exponential
energy, divided by kT, right?
So energy is one
half mv squared, kbT.
And mv, v is now
the random velocity,
minus the average
velocity squared.
It doesn't matter.
So that's a displaced.
So v is the random velocity.
And [INAUDIBLE] the
phase space velocity.
And if you average v, you
get a average velocity, u.
So you subtract
that amount, this
is the Boltzmann distribute,
displaced Boltzmann.
And then I have n, the
density, in the front.
And I forgot whether the m is
the denominator or numerator.
So m, 2 pi, kbT, 3
[? Hoffs ?] and exponential.
So now I'm going to replace
in my relaxation time
approximation, replace f0 by fd.
And this, of course, it
means in my current problem,
when I have a laminar flow, long
zero velocity is the only u.
I want to make my life easier.
So what I have is a
vx minus u squared,
plus vy squared,
plus vz squared.
And divide by 2 kbT.
The rest is the same.
So this is my fd.
And in this case, I'm
going to replace f0
by fd, displaced Boltzmann.
So this is f0, fd.
This is dfd.
Now I have to do
that derivative.
Go back to my general solution.
Again, say I don't have a
force acting on the molecule--
as long as I forget about
gravitational force.
Pressure is not a force in
my picture, it's a momentum.
So I drop this.
I have v, df, d, d, r--
so r, remember in here,
this u is a function of y.
vx, vy, vz, are again,
my phase based variable.
They are independent of xyz.
So I'm going to
sum up vx, vy, vz.
My real term is here.
So if I look at my f is there.
fd, minus tau.
And if I look at this, v
[INAUDIBLE],, creating the rfd.
What I have here?
I have-- because when I do this
gradient with respect to r,
I have dx, which cancels,
because nothing depends on x.
I have dy, because u
is a function of y.
u is a function of y.
So I have the y term.
So I should keep vy,
because it's v dot gradient.
So what I have here
is tau vy and df 0 du.
And times du, dy.
This is my solution for the
Boltzmann equation casted
under the current problem here.
So I have f.
My [INAUDIBLE] is going to
calculate the shear stress,
in terms of the
distribution function, f,
and the random momentum
space variables.
So what's my shear stress?
So when I consider
what's a shear stress,
I have velocity flow, vx.
The molecule is
doing random motion.
I have vx, vy.
So the shear stress is due to--
so in the tau xy.
What's my tau xy?
What's the shear stress?
It's due to the momentum
exchange in the x direction
going across the plane y.
The molecule go
carry momentum, mvx.
And because the component,
some of this molecule
going down, sometimes going
up in the y direction.
So it's that
exchange of momentum
in the y direction across
this plane of the x momentum
component gives me
the shear stress.
So when I do the
shear, tau xy, and I
will have to integrate now.
I'm not doing
[INAUDIBLE] because I'm
using Maxwell
distribution-- vx, vy,
vz are treated as a
continuous variable.
So I have minus infinite to
plus infinite integration limit.
And my shear stress is mvx,
That's movement in x direction.
The rate of change
in the y direction,
that's the molecule
going across the plane.
That will give you
the molecular level
expression for shear stress.
And the f, dvx, dvy, dvz.
So now you substitute
your f we have here.
And you do an integration.
And this is a good example
where your question again,
is do I convert it into
a spherical coordinate?
Do I keep the original
[INAUDIBLE],, vx, vy,
vz coordinate?
Or you want to convert it
into v, the energy, right--
mv squared.
And for this example, it's
much easier to actually keep
separate-- vx, vy, vz--
and do your integration.
So this is where
I say, once you're
comfortable starting
point, writing this down.
And the rest is your
own [INAUDIBLE] choice,
which you do.
In fact, if you
jump a few steps,
this term always drop out.
The equilibrium term
always drop out.
And you do your math,
it's due to symmetry.
It's an odd function.
When you integrate from minus
infinite to plus infinite,
it cancels out.
Physically, what it means is
because the f is isotropic--
in each direction is the same--
so if you look at the
solution f0, and f0--
f is an f0 solution,
superimposed with a deviation
term.
So deviation term, in the
case of heat conduction,
in the forward
direction is a positive,
in the backward
direction is a negative.
So it's actually this imbalance,
this is your g we drew before.
That's your g, the difference
between f and the f0.
It's this imbalance that's
giving the left flux.
f0 itself is the equivalent.
They're equal going
forward, going backward,
so there's no left flux.
Now when I have transport this
one in the forward direction
more, in the backward direction
less, so the imbalance give me
the heat flux, and give me
momentum flux-- all this.
That's the physics behind
this mathematical expression.
So if I substitute this
in, and what you find out
is I write it m 2 pi kbT, 3/2.
And I'm going to
pull this tau out.
I'm going to do a
constant relaxation time.
And relax time, there are
different model again,
for relaxation time.
And minus infinite
to plus infinite--
and it turns out, exponential
mvz squared, 2 kbT.
And dvz-- so I'm doing
each term separately.
And I have my other
two terms and I
want to write this
out just to emphasize,
when you do a
different problem, you
may have to choose your
different coordinate.
And that's your freedom.
vy squared, 2 kbT--
so this is the dvy.
And then vz, minus
infinite to plus infinite.
And mvx, minus u.
And this is a kbT.
That's what it comes around
for df0 du, because the df0,
du have this u in the exponent.
That's what I have here.
And exponential minus mvx,
minus u squared, and 2 kbT.
So dvx.
And then also, I have
in the front eventually
I have the du, dy.
That's the Newton
shear stress law.
I pull it out, because nothing--
this is a real space quantity.
It's not integrated
over the momentum space.
So you can integrate each one.
You can look at the
integration table
if you don't know how to
do those integrations.
And you'll find out at the
end, those are all constants.
So what I have is really
viscosity expression.
So what I'm going to get
out of this, all of this--
This one I'll have
n tau, kbT, du, dy.
This is my Newton shear
stress [INAUDIBLE] du, dy.
So I have now expression for
viscosity of the molecules
is n tau kbT.
You can also do the
thermal conductivity.
This is the momentum.
You do your energy, you
get thermal conductivity.
So thermal conductivity,
k, for gas molecule,
is you do your mass.
You'll get the 2/5 kbm, kbT.
so it turns out
[INAUDIBLE] times n tau.
So it's relate to
viscosity kbm mu.
So thermal conductivity is
related to the viscosity,
[INAUDIBLE] molecules.
and there are a lot
of this relation,
for example, in electricity
we're getting in soon.
The electrical
activity is related
to thermal conductivity.
That's all because there's
just a different integrals
of the Boltzmann equation.
I mean, this integral, what
you have here, for example,
is relaxation time.
And a different
molecular expression,
whether it's a shear
stress, vy times mvx,
or it's energy of
1/2 mv squared.
That's you're doing
the integration
of different functions,
different components
carried by the same molecule.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GANG CHEN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: One thing
usually we say
the Boltzmann equation is
for very weak scattering
and for diluted limit.
GANG CHEN: Right
AUDIENCE: Here, why it can
apply to the shear stress law?
GANG CHEN: I didn't
say applied to liquid.
You're going to do-- this only
apply to gas, gas molecules.
OK?
You can't apply
this to the liquid.
So it's a very
good comment there.
And in fact, the
other comment I have
is if you do viscosity
thermal conductivity
ratio, you can't get the Prandtl
number right, what I have here.
That's because the relaxation
time approximation.
If you do not use approximate
relaxation time approximation,
you can actually get your
Prandtl number right.
So in verified gas
dynamics, in gas dynamics,
people have done this--
solved the full
Boltzmann equation.
And I said, I made
some comment before,
if you want to find the
past resurgence on Boltzmann
equation, you go to gas
dynamics, then other work,
due to the mentioned
Apollo project,
when spacecraft goes through
the outer atmosphere.
Or you do neutron scattering.
People have done neutron
scattering is also
based on Boltzmann equation.
Or you do photon transport
And for photon and electron,
that's a later development.
So a lot of those, you can
actually use those other--
development in other fields.
The mathematics is the same.
The equation is the same.
OK.
So now we have heat momentum.
Let's do charge.
Electron transport.
So I'm going back
again to say how I'm
going to write f for electrons.
And first, recall in
the case of discussion
the Fermi particle,
the electron,
will have Fermi Dirac
distribution, which
involves exponential,
e minus mu kbT plus 1.
So this gets a lot
of complication.
Conceptually, it gets
a lot of complication.
Of course, your temperature
could be a function of space.
And mu, we typically call
the chemical potential,
and could also be a
function of space.
And in fact, if you
recall how we define mu,
in the case of
equilibrium, if I have,
for example, let's consider
only maybe a conduction band
of a semiconductor.
Conduction band, [INAUDIBLE].
Let's say here is my
energy wave vector.
And the way we, in
the under equilibrium,
you see the number of
charge is a summation
of a spin of all
modes and each mode
is the Fermi Dirac distribution.
This actually give
us either equilibrium
at a certain temperature--
using this, I can find.
Because the given
temperature, I can universally
find out what's the
chemical potential
if I know the number
of charge and if I
divide by per unit volume.
Here I will have the volume
is divided to the other side.
And of course, what
we did before is
this is a day Fermi Dirac,
this is density of states.
This is an energy integration.
This is what we did before.
One more step-- because
the density of states
is a constant times E minus Ec.
Ec is the bottom of
the conduction band.
Density of states-- in the
front is a relatively you factor
mass, you can now sit
there and write yourself.
I'm not writing that.
I'm just saying,
that's a constant.
Each measure has
its own constant.
And the point I want
to make is that OK,
if I integrate Ec
to infinite, I'm
just considering how many
electrons in the conduction
band.
With this, I'll find that
the f, the chemical potential
in the expression.
But what I want to make
now is a very subtle.
This is really confusing.
I was reading a
book this weekend.
This is a book on solar cell.
And specifically,
there was a paragraph
by the author commenting
on this, saying,
students don't understand
that you will not
be able to measure
electrical field.
You measure
electrochemical potential.
And they say, our
education has a problem.
That's the author's
comment in the book.
And so, it's a very
confusing point.
I hope you'll go
through with me.
Because what I'm talking
here is if I think about,
this is relate to--
the confusion comes from you
have electrons, you have holes,
you have positive charge,
you have electric fields,
you have chemical potential.
What are you measuring?
And so here, the
electric field--
if I think about the
energy of the electron,
is this is the kinetic
energy in the band--
1/2 mv squared.
And then there's a
potential energy, Ec.
That's the bottom of the band.
So I say, OK, energy
is the Ec plus the Ek--
kinetic energy, because our
factoring mass approximation
write this Ek as 1/2 mv squared.
Recall, this is
Ek, h bar squared,
k squared 2m, effective mass.
It's like my
kinetic, effectively
like in my kinetic energy.
This energy is relative to Ec.
And this Ec is relative
to whatever reference.
This is where, where
is your reference?
In my book, I say there
is an absolute reference.
And in fact, I say, I don't
think in my book I even do it
that well.
The absolute reference, the best
is just to take it a vacuum.
Then everything is
actually below the vacuum.
So the vacuum is
here, you can see.
But then the energy is negative.
That's even more confusing.
OK, let's just
say Ec is relative
to absolute flat level.
And that could be a
function of x, then.
Ec could be a function of
x, because different points,
you could have a different
potential, relative to that.
So if I do this, I
rewrite it in terms of Ek.
Because the mu, if e
here, e is relative
to any absolute
reference, the mu
is relative to the
same reference.
But now I'm going to use
the E equals Ec plus Ek.
Then you'll find out
that what I have here is
I can do my coordinate
and transform.
Rather than dE, I do dEk.
So I will have Ek,
because E minus Ec is Ek.
And exponential Ek minus
E, mass of mu, minus Ec,
divided by kbT plus 1--
so, dEk.
I'm just doing my
coordinate transformation.
Rather than integrate
from Ec to infinite,
I go from Ek, that's
bottom to infinite.
And the point I want to
make is mu mass Ec, right?
We said that mu is relative to
whatever absolute reference.
Ec is relative to
the same reference.
So what I have is mu minus Ec is
wherever my [INAUDIBLE] mu is--
this is mu, relative
to absolute reference.
And it's really the difference
between Ec say and the mu.
That's the difference here that
appears in my lambda particle.
So it's the difference of Ec--
mu from Ec, that is
the chemical potential.
Chemical potential
determines the number
of particles in the system.
OK, so here, what
I have Ec minus--
mu minus Ec.
That's the separation
of mu from Ec.
This one I say, OK.
I'm going to do this.
This is my chemical
potential, Ef.
So now I have one
understanding is where
is the chemical potential.
Chemical potential
is the driving force
for mass diffusion,
mass transfer.
OK?
Degrading, and few
other quantities.
What's my electric field?
What's the f?
What's the force
acting on the particle?
Electricity-- we know the force
is related to electric field.
Anybody remember?
Basic relation?
Force, electric
field times what?
AUDIENCE: q?
GANG CHEN: q, charge.
Right.
If the electron is negative, E--
again, I'm just
going to carry q.
I assume a positive charge,
because it's very confusing.
And then electrical
potential is related to--
electrical field is
related to field,
they relate to potential.
And that potential, phi.
What is phi?
Anybody know the name?
AUDIENCE: Electrostatic
potential?
GANG CHEN: I'll put a e here.
This is electrostatic potential.
So you have
electrostatic potential.
And then the energy,
the potential energy--
that's where all of those
different units, right?
Electrostatic potential
is another energy unit.
So energy is q times phi e.
u, energy of the charge,
the q times phi e.
This has the unit as my e in
the energy diagram I drew.
phi e, it is
electrostatic potential.
And q, of course, if you
take q is negative e,
you gather all the same problem
you have to take care of.
But the force is relative
of potential, [INAUDIBLE]
or not-- it's universal.
Of the [INAUDIBLE] of
the real potential,
not the electrostatic potential.
So now with this,
I'm going back.
I'm coming back to here.
I'm going to do my gradient.
So what I have here is
I consider a conductor
and I have current flow inside.
And it's a semiconductor.
I have the [INAUDIBLE]
could vary.
And in fact, a phi e will
always be parallel to the Ec.
Electrostatic potential, because
the q is the potential energy
of the charge, right?
So potential energy,
the bottom of this
is where my electron
potential energy is.
So I will say, I can always
think that u is parallel to Ec.
And now I'm going to do--
I also may have a
temperature gradient.
So this could be--
I could have T is
a function of x.
And I have Ec is
I have a mu as function of x.
I have three.
But Ec mu is my--
later on, you'll see mu under
my relative, absolute references
in my electrochemical potential.
It's not just in my
chemical potential.
OK.
OK, sorry.
I have forgot another one,
my Ef I just mentioned.
Ef is the chemical potential.
Because here is mu
minus Ec is my Ef.
Chemical potential is
driving the mass diffusion.
So now I'm going to do my f0.
I'm going to write f0 equals
exponential Ek minus Ef
kbT plus 1.
This is under my
new mu minus Ec.
So my Ef is relative
to the point of the Ec.
So now I'm going to do my
f equals f0 minus tau vx.
So here I have vx and df 0 dx.
That's the first term, df 0 dx.
My second term is F, the
force, force will be then
my q, charge, times here,
what I have is electric field,
is a negative electrical
potential gradient.
Or is q-- this is my
Ec, so it's negative.
So what I have--
maybe I don't do q.
I will do my negative Ec dx.
That's force.
Is there-- oh yeah, I
should have a negative
in the front, right?
Negative in the front, because
there's a potential gradient.
Force is the potential,
negative potential gradient.
So that's my force
and df zero dp.
p is a momentum, right?
Here, you see my Ek
is p squared over 2m.
Is px squared, py
squared, pz squared.
mvx, mm, right?
mvx.
So this is a force
in the x direction.
That means this one,
it should be df 0 dpx.
So df 0, dpx.
But the f0 is not
a function of px,
it is through Ek, which
is the function of px.
So I use [INAUDIBLE]
again, is dEk, dEk, dpx.
So dEk dpx is what?
dEk dpx, will that
gave me just a px?
That's just a mvx.
So this term is mvx, and dEc dx.
OK?
So here, I will get another
vx, I get another vx.
So I will have similar vx.
But now df 0 dx.
df 0 dx--
Ef is a function of x,
T is a function of x.
So I'm going to write it into--
so when I do df 0 dx, I
know Ef is a function of x.
But here, I do df 0 dk--
dEk.
So I say, Ef and the Ek is
just a change of position,
negative positive sign, right?
So when I do my
first term, dEf dx,
I have to do partial,
right? df df df, df dx.
And df dT, dT dx.
I'm going to keep
my notation simpler,
so I'll always come
back into df dEk.
So I'm going to do df--
the first one is--
OK, df 0 dx is df 0 dEk,
negative, because here, I'm
really doing dEf d.
So dEf dx.
So they Ef take care of
my Ef as a function of x.
My second time takes care
of my T as a function of x.
And you do that, let
me write this into--
in that case, what I write is--
again, I write a d because
for my notation df 0 dEk,
I still want--
even though this is dT,
but I write the dEk.
So the difference with respect
to the dT is Ek minus Ef kbT.
And I have dTdx.
So I'm writing this
Ef as a function of x,
T as a function of x--
that derivative into 3--
2 terms.
Mathematically, they
are equivalent because
of this exponential function.
Well, I must stop.
I will stop.
And today, I have to
finish this one, OK?
So what I am going
to have then I'm
substituting in to all
the three terms now.
If after I substitute in to all
the three term, what I will get
is f equals f0 plus tau vx.
and I will have a
dEf dx, plus dEc dx,
plus Ek minus Ef and kbT
and dT dx and dEf df, dEk.
So this is a one, I combined
this term with this term,
with this term and
write this term here,
I get my final expression.
And one more step you can take
is these two together, dEf dEc,
you can see my mu, the chemical
potential, is Ec plus Ef.
That's relative to any
horizontal actual reference.
This is relate to
electrostatic potential, phi e.
This is related to the
chemical potential,
so my mu is
electrochemical potential.
What I have here is the
electrochemical potential
gradient.
And here is
temperature gradient.
So what you will see if I
continue in the next class,
I use this f, I can
calculate current flux.
And you have the first term is
the electrochemical potential
is always the driving
force of the current flow.
You don't measure.
You do not measure.
When you put a
voltage probe, you
don't measure
electrostatic potential.
You measure always
electrochemical potential.
That's what the book
was commenting, I say.
OK?
And you do battery,
you deal with
the electrochemical potential.
You do semiconductor,
you do [INAUDIBLE] time.
You do electrochemical
potential for the current flow.
When the electrostatic-- whether
you can measure electrostatic
potential--
in fact, there are
ways to measure.
For example, it's basically if
you have a p-n junction, right?
You have a semiconductor.
You have p type, n type.
And there's
potential difference.
One way to measure is a use
a cantilever atomic force
microscope.
Approach it, and the
electrostatic charge
will actually expel
this differently.
But when you put the
electrical lead there,
you always measure
electrochemical potential.
OK.
So that's the most
time, we're not
careful in talking about this.
And then it will take you a
long time to appreciate it.
It always confused
me, in the sense
that the charge is a negative.
Yeah.
OK, I'll stop here.